Speaker 1: Donald Trump had a normal one
the other day, uncontrollably posting
absurd videos to truth, social.
Speaker 3: Growth, censure.
Speaker 1: This seems to be the latest
thing where Trump is using truth social,
almost like a video blog where any time something
just happens, he has to go and record a video and
post it. I'm just going to show you what
was posted within just a few hours to give
you a sense of the way that this is all working.
Here is a video corruption at the highest level.
Speaker 3: It was just revealed that the
51 intelligence officials who claimed
Hunter Biden's laptop from hell was Russian
disinformation. We're not only lying, they were
coordinated by the Biden campaign itself.
Speaker 1: So obsessed with Hunter Biden.
Recording videos on a whim to try to go
after Hunter Biden. Continuing to present
no viable policy package for his presidency.
Speaker 3: Was corruption at the highest level,
and it was a hoax perpetrated by Biden,
Secretary of State Anthony Blinken and
Partizan intelligence officials to cover up
the truth about the Biden crime, family's
grotesque influence peddling and corruption.
Speaker 1: Okay, so. Everything he's saying
here is false. It's a lie. It's made up. And
again, just recording these videos on a loop.
Moments later, with a video about the fake news.
Speaker 3: For all of those media fools who say
everything was on the up and up with the 2020
presidential election and then got on to report
about 51 intelligence agents that wrote a letter
spreading disinformation about Hunter Biden's
famous laptop computer, knowing it was fake
and treasonous just days before the election.
You have committed. All right.
Speaker 1: I'm not going to play
all of this for you. I'm just giving you a
flavor. It's uncontrollable. Then another video
about who the hell even knows what.
Speaker 3: It turns out that Joe
Biden and the Biden White House knew
everything about the unconstitutional
raid by the FBI and DOJ on Mar a Lago.
Speaker 1: No evidence that this is true either.
Speaker 3: Despite their unequivocal denial,
they denied it. They said, We know nothing
about it. We know absolutely nothing about
it. We would never do such a thing. They lied.
Speaker 1: All right, so there's another. But
again, it's just he's doing like a video blog,
then posting a piece of an interview from Newsmax.
Speaker 3: But they are very good at two things
disinformation and cheating on elections. That's
what they do. You saw the disinformation with this
new revelation that this was incredible, that
51 intelligence agents totally lied. I think
it's treason. They totally lied just before the
election, right before the vote. They lied. And
they said that the computer, which had all
crimes on it was Russian disinformation.
Speaker 1: The computer had crimes on it.
So this is happening almost 24 hours a day
at this point in time. Think about where
we have gotten in 2023 on the cusp of a
major presidential election, a very, very much
contested Republican primary. You have Joe Biden.
Doing things and announcing a reelection campaign
that admittedly many Americans don't want. But he
is functioning as a president accomplishing
things. And Donald Trump sits at his house
recording 30 to 50 second video blogs about
conspiracy theories he either misunderstood
or just is blatantly lying about. That's the
contrast that we have. My real hope and I say this
as a non Biden cheerleader, if this race comes
down to Biden versus Trump, a rematch of 2020,
which would be an incredible situation in American
history. I hope Trump genuinely gets crushed and
then we can say goodbye to Trump's political
career once and for all. That would really be
a delightful outcome if that that's where this
ends up, if it ends up being Marianne Williamson
versus Ron DeSantis. Okay. Well, then that'll
be a different situation. But if it's Biden,
Trump, if that's the if the rematch narrative is
the one that ends, it ends up being the reality.
I want Trump to really get crushed and to say
sayonara to his political career. Let's take a
quick break. We'll be back with much more right
after this. The David Pakman Show is a community
supported program. This is as good a time as any
to suggest to you that if you'd like to support
the work we do, you can sign up at join Packman
dot com. It's very cheap, it's very quick and
it comes with great benefits including access
to the daily bonus show, commercial free audio
and video streams of the show and invitations to
member only town hall events. Very exciting stuff
you can sign up at. Join Packman Qcom. You can
use the coupon code indicted to get a discount.